seit gestern abend mehr als okay scheiße
ich kann das video nicht retten es gibt
nur eine möglichkeit ich muss los und
das habe ich wirklich noch nie gemacht
leute jetzt wie viele von euch noch
nicht gemerkt haben habe ich mein video
von gestern abend gelöscht und viele von
euch nachgefragt haben wie sich dieses
video gelöscht habe möchte ich heute mal
darauf eingehen warum ist gelöst hat und
warum ist löschen musste und wessen
schuld das ist zuallererst mal wissen
hier an der nordsee ist richtig toll ich
mein kumpel moritz sagt euch dieses
video kurz bei ihnen im garten aufnehmen
kann danke dafür morgens ganz geil
unglaublich auch noch nicht braun
geworden und wieder zeit im urlaub so es
war ein bisschen älter es macht nicht
nur bisschen sport am strand gebeten
wurde bei seinem anliegen doch mal ein
bisschen was
das gelöschte video um das es geht kam
gestern hatte ich vorgestern am abend
mit allen leuten hier aufgenommen
richtig cool ist das hat mir echt spaß
gemacht und war wirklich witzig
vorgestern aufgenommen gestern
geschnittene gestrige tag war chaotisch
leute wir waren nämlich vorgestern abend
feuerwehr die mit frechen gestern morgen
ließ den ko wasser natürlich gemacht als
die kuh war eine pause
selbstverständlich keine pause wir haben
direkt weiter gefeiert und direkt weiter
getrunken und es dort ganz entspannt und
sportlich zur mittagszeit nicht mir war
aber klar auf die egal wie ich jetzt
feiere ich muss nach dem feiern also
nachmittag war mein video schneider war
von anfang an klar für sich und dann
haben wir mittags gefeiert so waren in
irgendeiner bars und natürlich die bars
sogar offen man hat ein blick aufs meer
war richtig richtig geil da hatten dann
irgendwann war es für mich an der zeit
sei jetzt schluss mit feiern auch in den
tälern ich jetzt nach hause das video
also wenn ich nach hause gehabt das
video geschnitten betatest von diesem
video aus einer ich komme nach hause
eine halbe stunde sind auf einmal so ko
dass ich mich auf den boden legen das
hat den lukas blog vielleicht auch schon
gesehen dass ich mich auf den scheiß
fußboden legen und auf dem fußboden ein
schlaffer soko war ich in dem moment
dann habe ich auf dem fußboden halbe
stunde geschlafen wenn ich aufgewacht
habe das video weiter geschnittenes
fertig geschnitten hatte aber weiß
relativ spät war man hier ewig lange
hoch nicht und weil luca druck gemacht
hat nicht mehr zeit über dieses video
drüber zuschauer aus doch etwas länger
als 20 minuten video dementsprechend
etwas schon eine weile gedauert da
drüber zuschauer diese zehn minuten
hatte ich gestern abend einfach nicht
also was habe ich gemacht ich habe
gesagt okay wird zwar nichts schiefgehen
wird so alles passen mit dem video ich
langsamer hoch ja wir haben sie das
feiern gegangen perfekt oder haben wir
eine gute zeit gehabt und ich bin jemand
der nicht sofort die aufrufe und
kommentaren seien youtube video steckt
also ich laden wie die ohren schaue ich
mir eigentlich immer er am nächsten tag
die kommentare und die aufrufe an die
schifffahrt das ist irgendwie schlecht
gelaufen
was ist für euch aber so ist es bei mir
was ich aber gemacht habe ist mein
instagram nach hypotheken und da hat mir
jemand geschrieben
sebastian beste was in deinem neuen
video sieht man so bis hin durch deine
hose durch also wollte etwas geschenkt
hat nicht nur noch auf der party
ich habe mir gedacht ich muss sofort von
dieser zeit fahren denken ich muss
sofort dieses video bearbeiten das geht
gar nicht klar also bin ich sofort nach
hause gereist opa geschmissen irgendwie
linienverkehr haben youtube geöffnet
das video nicht versucht zu bearbeiten
und hat einfach nicht wirklich
hingehauen
man konnte halt wirklich eiskalt ist zu
dumm von mir dass ich gezeigt habe
man konnte wirklich mehr oder weniger
gut durch die badehose dichte an hatte
perfekte schauen und krasse sache leute
das lässt das nicht video hatten zu dem
zeitpunkt schon 30 oder 40 tausend leute
gesehen die so was sehen konnte einfach
durch die badehose durch meine beine ich
könnte mir so eine klatsche dafür dass
dieses video nicht voll durchgeschlagen
sagte gestern abend dem scheiß ich kann
das video nicht retten gibt nur eine
möglichkeit muss löschen und das habe
ich wirklich noch nie gemacht leute ich
kann mich jetzt gar nicht erinnern wann
ich das letzte mal ein video von youtube
gelöscht habe ich behalte normalerweise
jedes einzelne video was ich hochgeladen
habe auch auf youtube online aber dem
video ging es einfach nicht also hab ich
dann schweren herzens gestern nacht noch
ein video gelöst die ganze sache nur
weil ich mich über dieses video darüber
geschaut
viele leute nach gefahr kam unter
anderem auf twitter und weil es das
erste mal in meiner erinnerung ist das
nicht so oft gemacht habe möchte ich
einfach noch mal erklären warum das
passiert ist da für diese szene wie
heute da am morgen sollte wieder alles
nach plan doch das nächste video kommt
wieder ganz normaler content vielleicht
beim nächsten mal ohne badehose viele
zuschauer so weiter schreibt man die
kommentare was er machen würde wenn ihr
youtuber wer tiere merken world aus
scheiße ich habe mir in dem video um
ganze kleidung angehabt was würdet ihr
wenn ihr youtuber werse in so einem
moment denke ich habe meine kommentare
ansonsten könnt ihr wie immer hier oben
ein video update macht persönlich für
euch vorgeschlagen wurde und mein können
abonniert hier oben die neueste folge
von was es geht um ein format mit
unitymedia abchecken
gestern musste